desde esta plaza se dirigió el
levantamiento indígena en contra de la
colonia española hace 201 años aquí
sigue vivo el sueño de atanasio tzul el
líder maya que luchó por la libertad de
estos pueblos milenarios
realmente no nos ha hecho libres no nos
ha hecho libres sino más bien
seguimos siendo
estafados por el estado por los criollos
es una falsa independencia
yolanda es una líder quiche uno de los
22 pueblos de la nación maya para ella
la independencia abrió las puertas a un
estado opresor racista y excluyente que
les negó su identidad estamos en la
lucha para
liberar a nuestra gente para liberar a
nuestra cultura para liberar a guatemala
de todo este saqueo que estamos viviendo
ahora
en la aldea natal de atanasio tzul
gerardo comparte el deseo de lucha de
yolanda si nosotros tenemos una historia
enriquecedora en este sentido y que es
por la reivindicación que es por la
lucha y por estar en contra las
injusticias pues nosotros vamos a seguir
manteniendo eso y vamos a enseñar a las
futuras generaciones que vamos a seguir
luchando en esta región la resistencia
indígena se caracteriza por la lucha
contra los proyectos estatales y de
empresas multinacionales que buscan
explotar su territorio tenemos que
resistir a toda la fuerza del poder
del gobierno el poder el poder económico
el poder militar si ya estamos en
resistencia
mientras el bicentenario es motivo de
festejo para algunos en totonicapán y
los demás pueblos mayas la lucha por una
verdadera independencia sigue